for business announcement in the lobby
after this event there will be a booth
and you can buy your way into Hillsdale
College if you want do you guys just
marvel at all that stuff it's amazing to
me
thank you Matt I acknowledge the most
intelligent member of the cotton family
here tonight and I his wife please stand
up dear
and up come on come on Tom cotton is
from Arkansas which makes us cousins
he's from Harvard couldn't get into
Hillsdale and he's from the US Army
he's been remember the house and now a
member of the Senate so far he's always
been a legislator you can think what
kind of man he is by thinking what that
is legislation is a form of the
intellectual virtue of prudence and it's
the form that's closest to principle in
theory prisons has to do with
calculating figuring out what to do
amidst shifting circumstances
legislation is made longer than that
it's not the immediate circumstances
laws are supposed to last they're
supposed to not be about particular
people or particular things or
situations they're supposed to be
general that's thought to be a condition
of the rule of law if you've forgotten
that you can be forgiven because laws
are not like that anymore now the
Congress doesn't really make the laws
anymore now they're just details often
naming this person or that Tom cotton
opposes that he opposes it because you
can read about his the outrages he
commits all the time
but any he he is particularly guilty
because everybody knows he's pretty
smart he ought to know better but also
you can see it because what kind of
senator is he I happened to have known
Tom and Anna before Tom got into
politics and actually knew Tom and Anna
before they knew each other
I always thought Tom got lucky but then
he gets in the in the Congress and then
in the Senate and he knows how to do it
it's amazing so here's the thing he did
one of the first things he did it was
kind of crazy he sent a letter to the
mullahs in Iran about the deal that was
being negotiated and you know it isn't
right for a senator to interfere in the
foreign policy of the United States
except in one way he just brought a
little instruction to the mullahs about
how treaties get passed in America and
the fact that they have to go through
the Senate of the United States I
thought that was just great and also you
know aggressive and restrained in the
right measure he went with Conklin
congressman Pompeo to Geneva one time
you know in fact-finding missions are
supposed to be about finding out facts
and the fact the fact he found out was
that there were side agreements in the
Iran deal about inspection and those
were not going to be made public well
doesn't matter anymore
that deal has been rescinded but that
was international news today I just
going to talk about war he knows about
war he sought it he fought in it he
distinguished himself in it he didn't
have to do that chose it chose it when
he was a Harvard lawyer graduate as his
sister will tell you she's an Arkansas
girl just like my sisters he did last
got into a position where he was going
to make some money and what does he do
but up and join the army and then after
that the Congress in the Senate he said
got deep
fact for those who fight he was
appointed to the old guard which is the
oldest military unit in the United
States and they they now bury our war
dead
and he takes that was the utmost
seriousness he's a man who has the
capacity and also the station or
qualification to write a book about that
highly honorable subject and I can tell
you that the book is beautiful and I
welcome Tom cotton
thank you Thank You Larry thank you very
much for that kind introduction
it's good to be back at the Kirby Center
I want to thank Hillsdale College for
hosting me and my first public remarks
about my new book sacred duty which is
available for pre-order on Amazon every
headstone in Arlington tells a story
these are the tales of heroes I thought
as I put the toe of my combat boot
against the white marble I pulled a
miniature American flag out of my
assault pack and I pushed it three
inches into the ground at my heel I
stepped aside to inspect it making sure
it met the precise standard we had
briefed to our troops earlier that day
vertical and perpendicular to the
headstone satisfied I moved to the next
headstone to keep up with my soldiers
having started this row I now had to
complete it
one soldier per row was our rule
otherwise different boot sizes might
disrupt the perfect symmetry of the
headstones and the flags I planted flag
after flag as to the soldiers on the
rows around me bending over to plant
those flags brought me eye level to the
lettering on those marble stones the
stories continued with each one
Distinguished Service Cross Silver Star
Bronze Star Purple Heart
America's Wars marched by Iraq
Afghanistan Vietnam Korea World War two
World War one some soldiers died in very
old age other still were teenagers
crosses Stars of David crescents and
stars every religion every race every
age every region of America is
represented in these fields of stone I
came upon the grave site of a Medal of
Honor recipient I paused
came to attention and saluted Medal of
Honor is our nation's highest decoration
for battlefield valor by military custom
all soldiers salute the Medal of Honor
recipients irrespective of their rank in
life and in death we had reminded our
soldiers of this courtesy hundreds of
gravesites would receive salutes that
afternoon I planted this hero's flag and
kept moving on some headstones had a
small memento a rank or unit patch
military coin a seashell sometimes just
a penny or even a rock each was a sign
that someone maybe family or friends
perhaps even a battle buddy who lived
because of his friends ultimate
sacrifice had visited and honored and
mourned for those of us who had been
downrange the site was equally
comforting and jarring comforting as a
sign that we would be remembered in
death but also a reminder of just how
close some of us had come to resting
here ourselves I let those mementos
undisturbed after a while my hand began
to hurt from pointing in pushing in the
pointed gold tips of those flags there'd
been no rain that week so the ground was
hard I asked my soldiers how they were
moving so fast and seemingly pain-free
they asked if I was using a bottle cap
and I said no several shook their heads
in disbelief
apparently missing a bottle cap was in
grave sin on par with forgetting your
rifle or your night-vision goggles on
patrol in Iraq those kinds of little
tricks and techniques were not briefed
in that day's written order but rather
they get passed down from seasoned
soldiers details like this often make
the difference between mission success
and failure whether in combat or
stateside after
some good-natured ribbing at my expense
one of my private squared me away with a
spare bottle cap and we kept moving we
finish up our section got our last
section got word over the radio to go to
the Columbarium
an open aired building were thousands of
urns rested in niches walking down
Arlington's leafy avenues we passed
section 60 where soldiers killed in Iraq
and Afghanistan were laid to rest if
their families had chosen Arlington as
their eternal home
unlike into other sections of the
cemetery that day several visitors and
mourners were present some had settled
in for a while on blankets or lawn
chairs others walked among the
headstones even from our respectful
distance we could see the sense of loss
and grief on their faces once we
finished at the Columbarium mission
complete came over the radio and we
began the long walk up Arlington's hills
and back to Fort Myer in just a few
hours that afternoon we had placed a
flag at every gravesite in this sacred
ground
more than 200,000 of them from President
John F Kennedy to the unknown soldiers
to the youngest privates from our oldest
Wars every hero in Arlington had a few
moments that day with a soldier who and
a simple act of remembrance delivered a
powerful message to the dead and the
living alike you are not forgotten that
day the Thursday before Memorial Day is
known as flags in at Arlington National
Cemetery and the soldiers who place the
flags belong to the third United States
infantry regiment better known as the
old guard my turn at Flags an came in
2007 between my tours in Iraq and
Afghanistan the old guard is literally
the old guard the oldest active duty
Infantry Regiment in the army
dating back to 1784 three years older
than our Constitution itself the
regiment got its nickname in 1847 from
Winfield Scott the longest serving
general in American history Scott gave
the regiment the honor of leading the
victory march into Mexico City where he
directed his staff to take your hats off
to the old guard of the army the
nickname stuck
perhaps Scott felt an old kinship
himself toward the 3rd infantry because
he had fought the British alongside them
outside of Niagara Falls 33 years
earlier in the war of 1812 but the old
guards performance and the Mexican War
also merited the honor by itself among
the few regiments to participate in both
of the major campaigns of the war
Monterrey in 1846 in Mexico City in 1847
the old guard made history alongside
American military legends the young
lieutenant later wrote that the loss of
the 3rd Infantry and commissioned
officers was especially severe in the
brutal street-to-street fighting in
Monterrey that lieutenant name was
ulysses s grant likewise the 3rd
Infantry was part of the main effort the
next year at the Battle of Cerro Gordo
the last stand on the road to Mexico
City by the famed Mexican general
Antonio Lopez de Santa Ana the Mexicans
had a numeric numerically superior force
on the high ground of both sides of the
only passable road on the way to the
capital but Santa anta had
underestimated the Americans ingenuity
and audacity with a young captain of
Engineers blazing the path the 3rd
infantry hacked through the jungle and
crossed many ravines to attack the
Mexicans from their rear finishing them
off with the bayonet charge that
captain's name was robert e lee and to
this day across the river the old guard
remains the only unit in the army
to March with bayonets fixed to their
rifles in honor of their forerunners
bravery at Cerro Gordo like those two
antagonists the old guard returned to
the battlefield in the Civil War
fighting with other so-called regulars
the career professional soldiers of the
federal government as opposed to the
volunteer soldiers of the state
regiments the old guard fought every
major battle on the eastern theater of
the war from the First Battle of Bull
Run to Gettysburg where they helped hold
off Confederate charges against the
weakened salient in Union lines in the
wheat field watching from the nearby
Round Top hills a state militiamen later
wrote for two years the regulars taught
us how to fight like soldiers at the
wheat field at Gettysburg they taught us
how to die like soldiers though out of
the fight the regiment later served in
Grant's headquarters at Appomattox
Courthouse a hundred and fifty-four
years ago today as he accepted the
surrender of their old Pathfinder from
Cerro Gordo after the war the old guard
went west as the American frontier did
and ultimately to the Philippines at the
turn of the century they fought under
General John blackjack Pershing they
fought against Muslim radicals and
places like Mindanao and Jolo where the
Islamic state and al Qaeda have
franchises today they guarded our
southern border with Mexico from Pancho
Villa during World War one and they
trained the vast new army of recruits
for world war ii before deploying to
europe in the final months of the war
when they returned for more the army
assigned its oldest unit to its most
sacred ground Arlington National
Cemetery
the Cemetery still calls it our nation's
most sacred shrine and with good reason
to borrow from Tocqueville in a
different context as rolling hills
seemed called by some secret
design of Providence to become our
nation's preeminent cemetery George
Washington's adopted son
Martha's only surviving son bought that
land bought the land that became
Arlington in 1778 to be closer to his
mother the only father he had ever known
and their beloved Mount Vernon George
Washington advised him on the purchase
and correspondence from his winter camp
at Valley Forge but our national
triumphs three years later at Yorktown
shattered the family's dreams their son
died of a fever contracted their leaving
behind the six-month-old
heir to his land George and Martha
raised that boy George Washington Park
Custis as their own wash as he was known
watched up close as General Washington
became President Washington when wash
came of age and inherited the land in
1802 he initially christened it Mount
Washington in honor of the adoptive
father he revered so much though he
later renamed it Arlington washed used
the land as a kind of public memorial in
his lifelong mission to honor his father
from hosting celebrations on
Washington's birthday to displaying
artifacts and memorabilia from Mount
Vernon and Washington's campaigns for
the public to building the grand mansion
still visible in the Lincoln Memorial
and Memorial Bridge Arlington got its
start as a shrine to the father of our
country a new resident arrived in 1831
when then lieutenant robert e lee
married washes only surviving child
mary lee himself was the son of
washington's trusted cavalry commander
during the Revolutionary War and for 30
years
the Lee's made Arlington their home and
raised a family there between his
military assignments because of these
ties to washing
and his own military genius and the fame
derived from both leah was offered
command of a Union Army as the Civil War
started but he declined it on the spot
his longtime mentor none other than the
3rd Infantry Szold commander
Winfield Scott and now President
Lincoln's general and chief scolded Lee
he said Lee you've made the greatest
mistake of your life but I feared it
would be so Scott encouraged Lee to
resigned his commission which Lee did a
couple days later in a letter written
from Arlington House Lee left Arlington
for Richmond that day never to return
and the United States Army occupied
Arlington on May 24th 1861 and it has
held the ground ever since
Arlington at first became a military
post key terrain to the defense of the
Capitol the old guard even camped there
for a few days in the summer of 1861
before the First Battle of Bull Run but
as the horrific war ground on casualties
mounted and Washington's cemeteries
filled up Montgomery Meigs the
quartermaster general and Edwin Stanton
the Secretary of War two tested robert e
lee as a traitor and saw a double
opportunity by turning arlington into a
Union Cemetery they gained hundreds of
acres of new land for graves while also
foreclosing Lee's return after the war
on May 13 1864 private William Chrisman
was the first soldier interred at
Arlington thousands more would soon join
him fixing Arlington as a new National
Cemetery or so they thought Lee's son
had inherited the family's claim to
their old farm himself a Confederate
officer his name never less reflected
the nation's deep roots
at Arlington George Washington Custis
Lee known as Custis he petitioned
Congress to no avail
and ensued in federal court to evict the
army as trespassers in the old family
farm United States v Lee worked its way
over the years to the Supreme Court
which finally upheld the Lee's family
claim but fortunately for the government
for the nation and for the souls at rest
in Arlington Custis was magnanimous in
victory asking only for just
compensation and in 1883 he deeded the
land back to the government in return
for a hundred and fifty thousand dollars
the Secretary of War who accepted the
deed was Robert Todd Lincoln the son of
President Lincoln after that final act
of reconciliation between the firstborn
sons of a great president and his fame
Breville antagonist Arlington's dead
could finally rest in peace for eternity
perhaps then it is fitting perhaps
another one of those secret designs of
Providence that are our nation's oldest
regiment found its final home and our
nation's most sacred ground in 1948 when
the oath the old guard became the Army's
ceremonial unit an official escort to
the president for 71 years the old guard
has marched in inaugural parades and
performed ceremonies at the White House
and the Pentagon and provided color
guards and drill teams or events around
the Capitol among many other missions
but one mission takes priority above all
else military honor funerals in
Arlington National Cemetery
funerals first that was our standard in
my day and it remains the standard today
in Manning and training and operating
funerals always come first for the old
guard funerals are as we said a no-fail
zero defect mission while we often
perform more than 20 funerals in a day
we knew that for the Fallen and their
families each funeral was a
once-in-a-lifetime moment a lifetime in
the making no matter how often we
conducted funerals and most of us
performed hundreds and hundreds of
funerals the pressure to achieve
perfection for the Fallen and their
families never relented
Lieutenant Colonel Allen Kehoe is the
battalion commander in charge of old
guard funerals today he has served with
the elite 75th Ranger Regiment and is a
five-time combat veteran yet he told me
I've never experienced pressure like
this anywhere else in the army he paused
and added I know that sounds crazy
perhaps the Sun but not to me and not to
his soldiers we felt that same pressure
every day in Arlington the pressure to
perform our sacred duty to honor
America's Heroes nothing interferes with
the old guards mission in Arlington and
when I say nothing I mean nothing not
even 9/11 on that beautiful morning the
nine o'clock funerals were underway when
American Airlines flight 77 slammed into
the Pentagon blasting debris across
Washington Boulevard and into the
cemetery's southeastern corner the old
guards medical platoon rushed to the
scene becoming the first soldiers to
deploy to a battlefield in the war on
terror
yet those yet those nine o'clock
funerals continued so did the ten
o'clock funerals and the 11 o'clock
funerals and over the next month even as
hundreds of old Guard soldiers pulled
guard duty at the Pentagon and carried
remains from that crash site funerals
never stopped in Arlington last
was no different during the state
funeral of President George HW Bush as
the nation awoke to news of his passing
the old guard had art assembled in the
pre-dawn darkness Saturday morning at
Fort Myer over the next six days
hundreds of old guard soldiers would
honor the old aviator in Texas at
Andrews Air Force Base and the Capitol
and Washington National Cathedral yet
far from the limelight funerals in
Arlington continued as planned as one
old Guard soldier told me our standards
remain the same whether it's President
Bush or a private first class whoever we
laid to rest we spent hours preparing
for that last perfect moment of Honor to
our fallen old guard companies have
industrial quality press machines and
their barracks to achieve those
razor-sharp
creases on their uniforms we measured
uniform insignia out to 160 fourth of an
inch sitting down in uniform between
funerals was prohibited to avoid
wrinkles we prepared for funerals in
sweltering summer heat in winter
blizzards and driving rain even when
inclement weather shuts the cemetery to
the public it doesn't stop the old guard
from performing funerals on time and to
standard we constantly practiced and our
Hurst each morning casket teams
practiced at folding the flag even
though they had folded a flag hundreds
if not thousands of times before bowring
parties practice their three volley
salute volleys that they fired dozens of
times every day in the cemetery we
talked through key sequences and cues
before each funeral sometimes conducting
the very same talk through six times in
a day nothing was taken for granted for
rare complex funerals the old guard goes
to even greater lengths
I participate in once in a group burial
for 12 soldiers killed in a helicopter
crash in Iraq we rehearse the mission
for several days in a row
to be sure it was perfect last year the
old guard dedicated the newest 27 acres
of the cemetery by laying to rest to
unknown Civil War soldiers whose remains
had been recently discovered at the
battlefield of 2nd Second Battle of Bull
Run soldiers involved rehearsed that
mission six times before performing it
researchers believed incidentally that
those two soldiers may have died from
wounds suffered during the union's
failed assault on the third and final
day of the battle an assault in which
the old guard participated and Arlington
is not the only site of the old guards
no-fail mission to honor our fallen
since the earliest days of the Iraq war
the old guard has performed the
dignified transfer of remains at Dover
Air Force Base in Delaware where our
nation's fallen soldiers returned home
for the last time my tour with the old
guard coincided with the surge in Iraq
so sadly we had Dover missions almost
every night they typically happen at
night given the flight times and the
time zone changes but whatever the time
whatever the conditions the old guard
was there when their remains landed no
question asked my soldiers my my
soldiers and I once drove to Dover two
days early to get ahead of a potential
blizzard if a soldier was coming home
the old guard would be there to honor
him most Americans have seen the iconic
photographs of flag draped cases at
Dover you have stood among them on that
windy ramp but old guard soldiers have
we've stood alone in the cargo hold
inspecting the flags for the slightest
deficiencies restrained with the heavy
case of a soldier
still in full combat gear packed in ice
and we felt the lightweight cases of the
dissociated remains of a soldier killed
by an improvised bomb the enemy's most
deadly weapon in Iraq and Afghanistan
we've saluted from the airplane as the
remains were driven away to be prepared
for return to their family these lonely
and poignant moments at Dover like the
old guards and flagging dedication to
our fallen in Arlington and his conduct
of flags in over Memorial Day weekend
tells not only a story about our war
dead and the soldiers who honor them but
also a story about the nation on whose
behalf they serve we go to the greatest
lengths to recover fallen comrades we
honor them in the most precise and
exacting ceremonies we set aside
national holidays to remember and
celebrate them we do these things for
them of course but also for us living
their stories of heroism of sacrifice of
patriotism reminds us what is best in
ourselves and they teach our children
what is best in America in doing so we
assure our fighting men and women around
the world that they too will be
remembered in death and their families
will be cared for a mutual pledge that
shaped our identity as soldiers and our
willingness to fight and if necessary to
die for our country it is well that war
is so terrible or we should grow too
fond of it
remarked robert e lee as he watched his
army slaughter Union troops at
Fredericksburg no one understands that
lesson better than the soldiers who have
fought our Wars on the front lines and
the soldiers who have honored their
sacrifices at places like Arlington and
Dover we know that sometimes our nation
much
wage war to defend all that we hold dear
we also know that terrible costs
inflicted by war
no one summed up better what the old
guard of Arlington means for our nation
then did sergeant major of the army Dan
Dailey he shared a story with me about
taking taking a foreign military leader
through Arlington to lay a wreath at the
Tomb of the Unknown Soldier sergeant
major major Dailey said I was explaining
what the old guard does he was looking
at the window at all those headstones
after a long pause still looking at
those headstones he said now I know why
your soldiers fight so hard you take
better care of your dead and we do our
living thank you
[Applause]
Cemetery is actually it the first
national cemeteries actually at the old
soldiers home where President Lincoln
summer cottage was and there were lots
of graves there how who made the
decision whether somebody was buried
there or at Arlington
yes ma'am the old soldiers home up in
Northwest Washington where President
Lincoln did go to get away from this
summer heat of Washington was an early
National Cemetery it's also today still
part of flags in old gar the old guard
sends a detachment of soldiers there on
the Thursday before Memorial Day to put
flags at every gravesite there as well
it was one of those cemeteries that
started to fill up in the Civil War
especially by 1864 when grant took
command of the Army and the East and
they began the brutal Overland campaign
so this was part so Arlington was part
of Montgomery Meigs and Edwin Stanton's
designs both to handle the remains that
were beginning to stack up in Washington
but also to foreclose leaves returned
forever the government had had seized
the title of Arlington they knew and it
turned out to be correct
couple decades later that their title
had a cloud on it and that they were apt
to lose in court but Montgomery Meigs
and his aide two camps were very clear
in their correspondence with each other
that they wanted to start burying Union
soldiers not just on Arlington but
specifically in the back yard of
Arlington House on the edge of Mary
Custis Lee's garden so even if the Lee's
ever claimed legal title back to that
land they would find it inhospitable to
live there now actually William Chrisman
is not buried in the backyard of
Arlington House he's buried almost as
far away as you can get from Arlington
House on the northern edge of the
cemetery if you're at Iwo Jima or the
Netherlands Caroline you can actually
see his gravesite the reason for that is
is the Arlington House was used as
headquarters for several captains of
engineers and when the grave team showed
up
they didn't want to have Union soldiers
buried in the backyard of their
headquarters any more than the leaves
would have liked to have them buried in
the backyard of their home so they
started sending the remains down to the
river for interment so Montgomery me
showed up a little while later and
realized his orders had been disobeyed
so he personally oversaw the first
burials in the backyard and he also
addicted all those captains and replaced
them with chaplains but that goes back
to the the practical problem that the
quartermaster general had in 1864 what
to do with all these remains in
Washington when cemeteries are filling
up and his political and legal strategy
to try to forever stop the Lee family
from reclaiming and returning to
Arlington say again besides Pierre
L'Enfant were there any other foreigners
there are there are several from many
different countries not many as famous
as L'Enfant but many many allies that
have fought with us particular in World
War one and World War two have soldiers
buried under certain circumstances there
today that would be very exceptional if
not require special approval of the
President but there are some foreign
soldiers buried there Larry at the
college we have a professor Tom Connor
who's an historian and he's written an
authorized history the battle monuments
Commission lately and I've been on a
couple of tours of cemeteries in Europe
American and others and he says
something you said which is that yeah we
in the British are better at burying our
dead than other nations and caring for
their remains why do you think that is I
think it's the mark of a civilized
people and a free people that we all
fight freely on defense of our freedom
and our way of life that we're not
conscripted we're not forced to fight in
that way there's more danger in front of
us than there is behind us which can't
be said for a lot of the world soldiers
and you know that that's a great book
about the battle monuments Commission
you know it's actually relatively new
development in human history that we
bring the remains of our soldiers home
in fact it was only in the Korean War
that we had what we call the policy of
concurrent return which soldiers are
returned as soon as they perish on the
battlefield in order one for instance
you know soldiers were generally buried
where they fail in Europe it was very
controversial in the aftermath of World
War one what to do with those soldiers
in no small part because our senior
generals and our diplomats didn't want
to dissing her over a hundred thousand
American soldiers mostly in France
because France had millions of soldiers
who had fallen and the French public
would understand lips told their leaders
that the Americans can disent her their
heroes and take them across an ocean why
can't you dissing her my son in northern
France and bring him home to me in
southern France so the army and our
diplomats opposed disinterring any
American soldiers however were mothers
and war widows protested and lobbied
Congress and as usually happens when
veterans and gold star families lobby
Congress they won and the generals lost
so we we allowed families to make the
choice there still I think about 31,000
Americans left in our European
cemeteries that are now superintendent
by the battle monuments Commission but
the rest of them came home me I went to
Arlington to include the order one
unknown the first unknown the Tomb of
the Unknown Soldier was dedicated on
Armistice Day what we mail call Veterans
Day in 1921 in an elaborate ceremony in
France and then in an elaborate ceremony
and state funeral here in Washington DC
and that was in fact modeled on a
unknown soldier who was so honored in
both the UK and in France the previous
year in 1920 yes ma'am
some years ago there was a an issue with
the headstones but showing up broken in
streams yeah so I wonder if you could
speak to that and secondly do you have
and I can you give us some information
on how many more can be buried at I'm
sure you're right that the cemetery
which is under the Army's jurisdiction
it's rare in that regard most cemeteries
are under the VA s cemetery
administration has had some troubles in
the last 15 years to include the
mislabeling of some grave sites as well
as headstones being discovered in some
of the wooded areas and streams and so
forth that was not an old guard
responsibility that's a different
command within the Army that managed the
cemetery the the senior leaders of the
cemetery at the time is about 10 years
ago were held responsible for that many
of them were relieved from that command
the old guard though as often happens
had to deal with the fallout of that so
for several weeks there was a team of
old guard soldiers who walked through
the cemetery after hours taking
photographs and cataloging every single
headstone in the cemetery and that's why
now if you use the Arlington website or
they're apt to find a headstone there's
a picture of it and it tells you exactly
what section and what grave it is in
because the old guard had to deal with
the although not responsible for the
cemetery had to deal with the fallout of
that that's not uncommon
as I mentioned the old guard deployed to
the Pentagon on 9/11 and they stayed
there for the next month helping
initially to pull the remains out of the
Pentagon and then sorting through all
the personal effects that's because
they're really the only large unit of
young infantrymen in the nation's
capitol to give you a sense of scale the
other four services have ceremonial
units as well that perform funerals for
their fallen in Arlington the old guard
is about two and a half times those
other four services units combined they
also provide contingency protection at
big big events so at the State of the
Union they're on alert and full
that gear if there were another kind of
civil disaster or terrorist attack in
Washington like 9/11 they also trained
for that as well that's one of their
third main mission after funerals and
after ceremonies so they often getting
pressed into duties like that simply
because as I write about in the book if
you'd like to read it it's the it's the
only unit that can provide manpower
there's thousands real manpower that can
get out and do back-breaking labor
there's thousands of troops in
Washington DC but they tend to be older
Colonels and generals or their aides and
assistants so if you want if you want an
army regiment that can do a tough job
the old guards really your only option
question about the cemetery so they just
added those 27 acres in the northern
part of the cemetery they took that in
Fort Myer Fort Myer and Arlington
National Cemetery were part of the same
plantation the old Custis plantation as
was what we now call George Washington
Parkway and Memorial Drive down to the
river the plantation went to the river
included where the Pentagon is as well
that will extend the life of the
cemetery out to about the 2040s or 2050s
there are plans underway some money has
already been appropriated by Congress
more is coming what is called the
southern expansion that will be down in
the vicinity of the Pentagon and the Air
Force memorial if you're familiar with
the area just east of the Sheraton Hotel
that will extend the life of the
cemetery into the middle of the next
century if we don't fight another major
war with large numbers of casualties
it's been a long time in this country's
history that we went that long without
fighting a major war and - I mean give
you my own personal experience when I
was at the old guard in 2007 and 2008
most of section 60 was still just an
open green field and today that section
is almost completely filled yes you
might mention the deployability old
guard I bumped into my godson who was a
first lieutenant of time in Djibouti in
December oh three
the army when it was stressed actually
deployed old guard elements as increment
and and I remember them they were
deployed in to Djibouti back in December
of oh three yeah Alex would go back a
little bit further than that I'll go
back to June 3rd 1784 when the old guard
was created because one thing I learned
in the research for this book is you
know the kind of rash precipitous
drawdown of our military that we see say
after the Cold War is not an anomaly it
is an American tradition after every
major war we have engaged in a very rash
and hasty drawdown of our military
forces until the enemy figured out
what's going on and we had to engage in
an equally rash and hasty build-up so at
Yorktown we had the equivalent of about
60 infantry battalions under arms by
1784 we had only two platoons left of
regular soldiers as they were called
that's fewer than a hundred troops
basically the garrison two forts so
Congress says they usually do came
around and realized they had cut too
deeply and that they the army the army
needed at least a cadre of professional
officers and noncommissioned officers to
form the core of an army and that's why
the old guard was created On June 3rd
1784 as the first American regiment and
it's a lot of the old guards evolution
resulted from that as well now why are
they called the third Infantry Regiment
not the first Infantry Regiment since
they're all after all were the first and
they were named the first American
regiment that's because after the war of
1812
we went from 48 regiments down to 8
regiments even though Great Britain was
still threatening us and they were
rolled into other regiments and they
were all numbered based on the seniority
of the colonel in charge of them so
that's why the old guard the oldest unit
is not known as the 1st Infantry
Regiment but the 3rd Infantry Regiment
so this pattern of rapid draw downs that
within and paying for whether an enemy
strikes or expensive buildups goes back
to the very beginning of our country in
the very beginning of the old guard and
yeah in late 2003 in the early days of
the Iraq war our army was strained so
much that army leaders at the time had
to take some very unusual decisions I
spoke and
and the research of this book for the
generals that were involved in those
decisions three of them in particular
stood out first we deployed one of the
brigades that we've long had stationed
on the Korean Peninsula to Iraq that
brigade is obviously there for a reason
it's not to fight expeditionary wars
it's to secure the peninsula but they
had to go to we deployed the permanent
opposition forces that we have assigned
to our two national training centers one
at Fort Polk in Louisiana one at the
National Training Center outside Barstow
California to fight in combat they're
excellent soldiers because all they do
is play the opposition force for
visiting units that are about ready to
go downrange ten times a year but the
third and probably the most striking
example of how strained their army was
is the army leadership made a decision
to deploy a company of old guard
soldiers out of Fort Myer for the first
time since 1948 to Djibouti where we
have a strategically critical base on
the red sea near the bab-el-mandeb
Straits that happened again two more
times I went to Djibouti during my time
at the old guard Delta Company deployed
I was in Charlie which meant it put a
great strain on us at the cemetery
because we'd lost a third of our combat
power so to speak in performing funerals
and and ceremonies and then in 2010 and
2011 my old company Charlie Company had
to go to Iraq so three times in eight
years because of improvident military
drawdowns the old guard had to deploy a
company overseas thank you so in
December my family and I had the
privilege to go and lay the wreaths on
all of the graves at Arlington and it
was very powerful and very humbling to
look back and see row after row of these
wreaths and I just wondered if maybe you
could speak to the history of that
sure so wreaths across America is a
great event it's not a government event
or an old Guard event although many of
its soldiers do participate in it it
started with a company in Maine that
made a lot of wreaths and they had
surplus wreaths so they decided the best
use for those were to put them on the
graves of our fallen heroes over time it
became more and more pop
they begin to get more corporate
contributions to build accessories it's
not just use surplus wreaths to the
point now that there's a major
foundation supporting wreaths across
America there's enough resources to put
a wreath on every gravesite in Arlington
but it also happens in cemeteries across
America not at every gravesite but you
know at our National Cemetery in Little
Rock for instance we also have people
that go out in December and put wreaths
at every gravesite so it is a great
tradition and if you'd like to
participate in it's open to the general
public it's pretty popular Arlington you
have to get there early if you want to
participate can you speak to the the
pledge to behavior that the soldiers in
the old guard make I understand this is
something they pledge to or ever so
that's largely an internet rumor I have
to confess and specifically the the
rumors are most rampant about the
sentinels of the Tomb of the Unknown
Soldier I suspect many of you have been
to the tomb and you've seen the changing
of the guard many people mistake the
tomb platoon as the old guard itself I
frequently get asked about guarding the
tomb I never guarded the tomb I was an
officer they didn't trust officer with
such a sensitive duty now to be fair
there are there have been officers have
been guards at the tomb in fact they
have a platoon leader today but it's
actually the exact opposite the tomb
platoon is the most distinct the most
separated platoon in the entire old
guard they don't do anything else they
don't perform funerals they don't march
in ceremonies they don't respond to
natural disasters or terrorist attacks
the only thing they do is guard the tomb
as we have every minute of every day for
82 years there are many rumors on the
internet about how those tomb guards
take a pledge not to speak for the first
six months that they're in the tomb
platoon that's not the case they
couldn't lay a wreath without being able
to speak and give instructions to the
civilians they take a pledge to never
swear again I have to
best I've seen Tim Gard swear once or
twice no never never on duty never on
duty they there's a rumor that they take
a pledge to never drink alcohol again
and I have to confess I've seen Tim
Guards drink a beer or three on occasion
although never again on duty but I do
think even the apocryphal those those
rumors shed light on the reverence that
our nation has for Arlington and for the
old guard and specifically for that tomb
and what it means for our nation you
know for the longest time it still could
happen today world war two veterans
still visit their every now and then for
the longest time and Korean veterans for
that matter thousands of veterans of
those Wars or widows or war sons and war
daughters could visit that tomb and they
had never seen their father didn't know
what happened to him and they could
imagine that that unknown from World War
One or World War two or the Korean War
was their son or their husband or their
dad and two more today will still tell
you that they see women dressed in black
mourning at the tomb young women younger
than Anna and me presumably a widow of a
soldier who died in Iraq or Afghanistan
so I think those rumors
although apocryphal are a good example
of exactly what that place mains
tarnation
more question and then like says if we
know the tomb guards drink alcohol nail
I know there's a little bit more out
there so don't want stand in your way
any longer thank you for coming out
tonight and everything that went into
the effort you have here do you know
what the ages are of the youngest and
oldest buried in Arlington I don't know
it's a good question and probably a
question whose answer could be learned
you know we buried we buried people and
they still bury people today from what
we're - so you're talking in the 90s if
not the hundreds and I would have to
imagine that there are teenagers well
under the age of 18 who have lied about
their age to enlist in old Wars so they
could go fight now unfortunately I can
tell you the the youngest people bear in
Norling t'en are a day old or less
because especially in some of the older
sections of the cemetery there's even a
section called the children's section
there are infants who are buried in the
same grave site as their father or their
mother
those grape sites can accommodate
several sets of remains typically a
soldier and husband or wife but if a
soldier loses minor child then that
minor child can also be eligible in
Arlington typically that's done in
advance so they sign sign a form that
pledges that they themselves will be
buried there whenever they finally pass
away but in the older sections of the
cemetery as I said there are hundreds
and hundreds of headstones that on the
back will simply say his son or his
daughter because the child died at
childbirth or in their first day without
ever receiving a name and fortunately
there's even like I said a section
called the children's section next to
Fort Myer in which several dozen young
children you know up to teenage years
died and I think it was the 1950s from
some kind of epidemic that happened in
Washington DC they were all the sons of
sons and daughters of the soldiers
stationed at Fort Myer at the time thank
you all
[Applause]